joining me now Texas governor Greg
Abbott Governor your response to Eric
Adams that at the core of your policy is
racism
it's kind of odd really Laura because
New York and Chicago they are
self-declared Sanctuary cities so you
would think they would be asking for me
to be busing migrants to their cities
the fact of the matter is Laura that
there are more people coming across the
border every single day than there are
migrants that are in Chicago or New York
and this is not a Texas problem this is
a United States problem and it's the
responsibility of New York and Chicago
and the entire country to deal with a
problem caused by Joe Biden and Joe
Biden's open border policies as you have
said before we can never forget the way
it was just a few years ago under
President Trump that we were at
multi-decade lows and the number of
people coming across the border now we
are at these record-breaking highs and
will get worse when title 42 is uh
repealed and the borders are opened up
and so Chicago New York and other cities
they need to step up and help out in
this crisis is caused by Joe Biden now
Governor right before you joined us
tonight Adams went on CNN doubled down
on his remarks we just got him in watch
I don't know if if it's to undermine
these large cities that are run by black
Mayors because of his political agenda I
don't know if he's doing it before the
race I'm giving the facts of where he
has sent them to we have a hundred and
eight thousand cities in America look
what he sent them to
your response to the mayor that you're
targeting these cities
actually their their cities are chosen
they're The Chosen cities by the
migrants themselves understand this and
that is every one of these migrants who
gets on a bus they volunteer to go and
they choose the city they go to they
want to go to New York they want to go
to Chicago and these other cities uh and
so it's this is a complete voluntary
process where again uh we're sending
them to Sanctuary cities that are
embracing and welcoming these migrants
who've come across the border
now Governor everyone thought this was
oh Biden's sending troops to the Border
I think there's already 2500 troops
there doing you know more clerical work
and processing work
we don't need to play uh the press
secretary on this but what do people
need to know about what these troops are
actually doing
let's be clear Joe Biden said that he's
sending 1500 Military troops to the
Border but in that same order said that
they would be doing paperwork Laura the
last thing we need are troops on the
board are doing paperwork we need more
border patrol officers we need the real
United States military to go down to the
border and take the action that
President Trump would have taken
well Governor this is a massive human
tragedy and a danger to our country's
security do we have any way of really
knowing who most of these people are are
a lot of them don't even have IDs
well so many of them do not have IDs but
the Lord the most dangerous part about
it as you know is the fact that in the
past year there have been apprehended
about a hundred people who were on the
terrorist watch list and you know the
people on the terrorists watch list they
pay extra to not be apprehended so who
knows how many terrorists have really
come across our border and are going
around the United States of America the
top duty of the president of the United
States is National Security and Joe
Biden has failed at that top Duty on our
Southern border yes or no is this an
impeachable offense what's what he's
done today I believe it is he he he
Laura he is failing to fulfill the
duties of his office his executive
powers he's not executing the
immigration laws that were passed by the
United States Congress I believe it is
an impeachable offense Governor thank
you so much hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else